so i don't know if you all have noticed
this about my videos yet but i always
try to explain the lore of eldon ring in
the most simplistic way i possibly can i
do this because eldon ring's lore is
already the most confusing storyline of
any medium i've ever tried to consume i
think of myself as an outlier in that
regard because you as a viewer
definitely don't need to click on a
video about a topic you're trying to
understand better but end up more
confused than you were before when you
finish it trying to put elden ring's
story in a concise understandable way
for all of you to watch and at the same
time the entertaining can only be put in
one way it's really hard but nothing in
life is worth doing unless it was hard
to begin with right so today i'm going
to try and explain a confusing area in
the world of elden ring known as
crumbling vera missoula there's a lot to
digest in this area there's many
theories as to what everything means and
why we end up in this area in the first
place it gets confusing so i will do my
very best to explain it in the most
simple way i can before we get into the
rest of the video this video is
sponsored by you guys and your support
here on youtube and on patreon the
growth on the channel has been
incredible lately so i'll keep making
videos if you guys keep enjoying them
our percentage of subscriber to viewer
ratio has been growing like crazy lately
so make sure to subscribe if you liked
the video all the way through also a
special thank you to the patrons you can
see on screen for the extra support if
you want early access to videos and
discussions go check out the patreon for
yourself that's where you can get access
with all of that said let's get into the
video
the one who walks alongside flame
shall one day meet the road of destined
death so what does melana mean by this
throughout our journey up to melania's
sacrifice at the forge of the giants
we've heard a lot about destin death
it's mentioned to us in many different
ways and can be confusing to understand
at times to make it less confusing
destined death seems to be a synonym for
the rune of death they go hand in hand
the rune of death was once protected by
the glomide queen and her followers and
they were responsible for dispersing
death to those destined to die hence the
phrase regarding the rune of death has
also been destined death in our final
moments with melna she tells us that she
has long observed the lands between that
the world is in dire need of repair and
death indiscriminate what she means by
this is that the dispersal of death
throughout the lands between since
malachite sealed the rune of death away
has been random without order or just
not happening at all that's why some of
the enemies we fight are seemingly
undead because they can't actually die
melania's task is to release the rune of
death or destined death back into the
world so that a new era may begin
hopefully as we become the new elden
lord so when she tells us that the one
who walks alongside flame shall one day
meet the road of destined death he's
referring to us walking alongside the
forge of the giants lighting the flame
and removing the impenetrable thorns
which stop us from our destined fate
which is to become the new elden lord if
you haven't found it yet there's a
secret room when you take the lift down
to the forbidden lance that holds the
blade of calling which reads dagger to
the one who set out on a journey to
fulfill her duty long ago the power of
its former owner the kindling maiden is
still apparent the one who walks
alongside flame shall one day meet the
road of destined death it's possible
that this small room was designed for
melana in order to fulfill what she is
meant to do which is to fix the lands
between and help us the tarnished become
the elden lord there isn't a ton to go
off of here but this might have to do
with queen america's plan to defy or
test the greater will and if you want
more information on that go watch my
video on queen america's perfect plan
now it may seem random that we wake up
in pharah missoula after melania
sacrifices herself but this is what we
were fated to do walk alongside flame so
that one day we will meet the road of
destined death the road is obviously
referring to pharam azula now this is a
from software game so it isn't really
necessary to dive into the logic of how
we just randomly wake up in pharah
missoula we are meant to speculate on
how and why we are here maybe melinda
just teleported us here after her
sacrifice because that was our next step
towards our destiny she teleported us to
the round table hold so it isn't too far
of a stretch or pharah missoula could
just be a dream or mental state i have
this long shot theory that pharah
missoula isn't actually real but is
inside of ourselves as a tarnished a
world developed by our guidance of grace
manifested within us but is in a
shattered state we are meant to mend the
shattering within ourselves and the
world as a whole with the elden reign i
also believe that the round table is one
of these dream states as well we can
find a different version of the round
table in the capital city it could be
along with pharah missoula a
manifestation of what once was in order
to continue down our path toward our
destiny but just like with the round
table in the capital city we can see
these ruins throughout the lands between
that are oddly similar to the floating
crumbling ruins of pharah missoula
itself i'm sure you've all found many of
these ruined fragments spread around the
world but when we read the item
description it states that these small
stone fragments are found near places
where ruins have fallen from the sky
these shards of stone are believed to
have once been a part of a temple in the
sky now we don't know for sure but it
could be that the pharam azula temple
was once above everything in the lands
between potentially located right above
limgrave ruins like the one we see
kenneth height standing on could have
fallen from pharah missoula itself when
it was once above stormville castle or
lim grave it's also been stated that
stormville once had much stronger winds
and storms surrounding it maybe this
could have been the location of pharah
missoula and the tornado or storm that
we can find there but why did farah
missoula move why is it now located so
far out to the east well like i said
before it could be just like the round
table it isn't actually in any type of
location it's on our map for us to
travel there of course but it isn't
truly there at least in the form that we
can find it in now i do think that
pharah missoula is physically out to the
far east beyond caled because we can at
certain points find grank outside of his
temple howling in the direction of
pharah missoula indicating that some
version of phara missoula is out there
to the east somewhere in regards to the
pharam beastmen we can learn from their
ashes that the spirits of beastmen from
doomed pharaoh missoula the slowly
crumbling ruins in the skies these ruins
are said to be the remains of a giant
mausoleum enshrining an ancient dragon
guarded by chosen beastmen who wielded
weapons clad in lightning we can see
tons of grave sites holding the bones of
fallen ferum beastmen who it looks like
have been chosen to protect their
dragonlord likely waiting alongside
their lord until their outer god returns
to them when we enter the dragonlord
fight we start to understand that time
can be altered in some way how is this
possible i have no idea why our
character knows to just lay down next to
a tornado i have no idea on that either
or just like our character knows to just
jump into a coffin i'll never understand
that part either it's a from software
game and trying to come up with
logistical answers to questions we may
have will just lead to more unnecessary
confusion when we earn the dragonlord's
remembrance it reads that the dragonlord
whose seat lies at the heart of the
storm beyond time is said to have been
elden lord in the age before the erd
tree once his god had fled the lord
continued to await its return who is
this felled god there's many theories
almost so many that it could make up its
own video but what i think is important
to understand is that in ancient times
dragonlord placidusex was the original
elden lord under a different outer god
before the greater will my theory is
that this felled god that the dragon
lord is waiting on is the three fingers
evidence towards this theory is that the
three fingers had been imprisoned below
the capital city for what feels like a
very long time and that the flame of
frenzy can only be subdued in the
dragonlord's boss room using mykola's
needle but there's just not enough there
to say concretely who this feld god is
if you guys have a theory of your own
please leave it down in the comments but
placidusex was likely defeated by
godfrey and at this point the greater
will took over the lands between under
the rule of queen america and godfrey
the new first elden lord the world of
the lands between that we play the game
in is not how it's always been i'm sure
that goes without saying we are sent
here initially for one purpose to mend
the elden ring back together and become
the elden lord and if you're like me
during my first playthrough that goal
never wavered i wanted to be the elden
lord but as i played the game more and
more and maybe more observant players
noticed this during their first journey
but we can clearly see while we're
playing the game that we have a major
effect on the world that we play in the
world is in complete disarray or it is
exactly where it should be certain
factions are thriving while others are
struggling to stay alive but what is and
isn't is completely up to us we are the
tarnish that can alter the next coming
era we can keep it the same or we can
change it drastically the lands between
is changing while pharah missoula seems
to sit in a purgatory state maybe it's
to keep destin death away from those who
would want to abuse it maybe it's to
hold the original elden lord in hopes
for a future with the ancient dragons
and their felled god maybe everything
has been carefully crafted by corrupt
individuals in order to change the world
or keep it exactly the same but the more
i play the game the more my intentions
of becoming elden lord changed the
guiding light that is meant to steer us
towards our destiny we come to realize
is only what the greater will
wants us to do it's not our destiny it's
the greater wills destiny when melania
sacrifices herself so that we may become
elden lord he wants us to finish what
we've started to fix the lands between
and release destined death back into the
world when we kill malakath he questions
our decision to release the rune of
death
with astonished
why cover destiny
to kill what
but what he doesn't know is that we
aren't trying to kill anyone in
particular we are here to mend the elden
ring and fix the lands between in order
to do this death must be dispersed back
into the world so that the lives of
those wandering aimlessly can finally
move on to whatever is next pharah
missoula is a beautiful representation
of what the lands between is currently
experiencing it's in a state of
nothingness after everything it once
knew was shattered instead of changing
it's held in this state holding on to
the past when we come into the world
when we release destined death we allow
the world to move on from the past and
can start a new era in any way that we
see fit or any way we've been
manipulated into doing
thank you
for guiding me here
[Music]
the one who walks alongside flame
[Music]
shall one day meet the road of destined
death
[Music]
thank you for watching and i really hope
you enjoyed the video make sure to
subscribe so that we can keep the
channel growing every single day the
support you all have been showing has
been a dream come true for me so know
from the bottom of my heart how much i
appreciate you guys have a great rest of
your day and i will see you all in the
next video take care